PROFESSOR: All right.
So let's get now the state n1.
So I want to make
a general remark.
You have an equation like this.
And you want to solve it.
It's a vector equation.
Operator and a vector
equal number and a vector--
a more operator and a vector.
To make sure you
have solved it, when
you have a vector equation
you must make sure
that every component-- you
can write a vector equation
in the form vector equals zero.
And then you must make sure that
every component of the vector
is zero.
What we did here
is we found what
happens when I look at
the component along n0.
And I figure out that,
whoops, this equation,
when I look at the
component along n0,
tells me what the energy is.
So the rest of the
information of this equation
arises when I look at
it along the components
on the other states, not n0 but
the k states that we introduced
from the beginning, the k0's
that run from one to infinity.
So what we're
going to do is take
that original--
this second equation
and form k0 h0 minus Em0 m1 1
is equal to k0 Em1 minus delta H
n0.
So I now took the same equation
and I put it in a problem
with k0.
And I say, look, k
will be different
from n, because
when we put k equal
to n that already we've done.
And we've learned all about it.
And, in fact, n1 didn't appear.
The state that we wanted
didn't appear at all.
So now we do this
with arbitrary k.
And we need to figure
out what this gives.
So you have to look
at these things
and try to remember a little
of the definitions with both.
So h0, we know what
it gives from k0.
It gives you a number,
the energy of that state.
So this is another number.
So that's great.
This simplifies this
to ek0 minus En0
times the overlap of k0 with n1.
That's the left hand side.
How about the right hand side?
All right.
Let's see what this is.
First term.
The En1 is a number,
so I must ask
myself is what happens
when k0 meets n0?
Well, those are our
original orthonormal states.
And we said that k
is different from n.
So this term is 0 with an En1.
This is a number.
And these two states
are orthogonal.
So this term gives you a 0,
not because this number is 0,
but because the overlap is 0.
And I get here
minus k0 delta H n0.
And it's good
notation to call this,
to save writing, delta Hkn
It's a good name for it.
It's the matrix k--
the kn-th element of the matrix
delta H. And this is a number
so I can solve k0 n1
is equal to minus delta
Hkn divided by Ek0 minus En0.
And this is true for
every k different for n.
And here we find, for the first
time, our energy denominators.
These energy denominators
are the things
that are going to make life
interesting and difficult.
And it answers the
question already
that if you had
degenerate states,
there would be some
k state that have
the same energy as this one.
And this blows up.
And this is unsolvable
for this component.
So you start
getting difficulties
if you have degeneracies.
As long as every k state--
all the other states
of the spectrum
have different energy from En,
nevermind if the other states
are degenerate.
They're not degenerate
with the state you care.
You care just about one
state now, the n-th state.
And if that's nondegenerate, all
these denominators are non-zero
and you're OK.
So here is the solution
for this thing.
Now I can write the expressions
for the state and the energy.
So let me do it.
So I have this n1 like that.
Now you can say the following.
Let me do this very
deliberately first.
n1 is equal to the sum
over all k of k0 k0 n1.
This is the resolution
of the identity formula.
That's the unit operator.
You can always do that.
And now you know that the
state n1 is orthogonal to n0.
So this becomes the sum
over k different from n,
because for k equal to n, these
are orthogonal of k0 k0 n1.
And that's what we
calculated here.
So what did we get?
Therefore, the state n1, I can
substitute what we had there.
It's the sum from k different
from n of k0 delta Hnk over Ek0
minus En0.
That's n1.
I should have a minus sign.
The minus sign is
there at the state n1.
So the state n1 is a
complicated correction.
It gets a little component
from every other state
of the spectrum.
And the coefficient depends
on the matrix element
of your state with the state
you're contributing with.
So you have the state n and
all the other states here.
The amount of this state k
that enters into the correction
is proportional to the matrix
element between n and k.
If the matrix element is 0, that
state does not contribute here.
And then there is the
energy denominator as well.
So we're getting to the
end of this calculation.
There's one more thing one
can do, which is to find--
so I'm starting to
wrap up this, but still
an important step
what we have to do.
I'll get the second
order energy correction.
What is our second
order energy correction?
Our second order
energy correction
can be found from the formula
on that blackboard, En2.
We already found the first
order energy correction,
which I happened to have
erased it right now.
It was there.
En2 is obtained by doing
n0 delta H times n1, which
we already know.
So I must do n0 delta H on that.
So look what you get.
You get minus the sum
over k different from n.
Think of putting the n0 and the
delta H, they're all together.
It's a [INAUDIBLE] so far.
It's a delta H and n0.
IT should go into n1.
But the only state in n1 is k0.
So here we have k0.
And then we have delta
Hnk over Ek0 minus En0.
OK.
A little bit of work.
So what is this?
This is another matrix element.
This is the matrix--
OK.
I'm sorry.
Here do I have a mistake?
Oh, yes, I have kn.
I copied it wrong.
It's kn.
Yes.
So here I have delta Hnk.
but delta Hnk is this.
If you complex conjugate--
if you complex
conjugate delta Hkn,
complex conjugate is k
delta H n complex conjugate,
which changes the order.
n delta H, which
is her mission k.
And that's delta Hnk.
So delta Hnk is equal
to delta Hkn star.
And therefore the second
order energy correction
has a nice formula.
En2 is equal to minus the
sum over k different from n.
Delta Hnk, which is the
star of that times this one,
so you get delta Hnk absolute
value squared divided by Ekn.
Ek0 minus En0.
So we've done a lot of work.
We've written the perturbation.
Here is the answer.
So far we have n of lambda
equal n0 plus lambda n1.
n1 has been calculated.
Energy is En0 plus lambda En1.
That was calculated
what was just
delta H in this state
plus lambda squared
En2, which we have calculated.
So this is as far as we will do
for nondegenerate perturbation
theory.
But we have found rather
interesting formulas.
And we're going to spend
half of its lecture trying
to understand them better.